- The guy is selling
things on the internet
only seven years ago, telling people
that if you drink this, it cures cancer.
(people mumble in agreement)
Who are you?
(confident hip hop music)
You got your perspective.
(audience roaring)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(relaxed music)
(upbeat music)
(mumbling) All right, bye.
Hello,
- How ya doin'?
- how are you, how's it been goin'.
- Good.
- Good?
Awesome, great, so in this part, I'd love
for you to go around
and give me some context
of who you are, and what you do,
and then we'll go back around, and I will,
I think this is where you
need to go very selfish
and specific, obviously it's unlikely
that you're here without some solid level
of context of who I am in theory.
So I think this is where we can get
very, very, very detailed, so go very,
very, very selfish with the question,
we'll see how many times we can go around.
(computer beeping)
- [Nedry] Ah ah ah, you
didn't say the magic word!
- Please, goddammit!
(upbeat music)
- Good to see you, (mumbles), how are you?
Great to see you, great to see you.
- Great to see you.
- I love you.
- Oh my God, it's amazing, we had,
such a breakthrough after the 4Ds,
and with the guidance
and advice you gave us.
And so we've been doing
that, we're actually,
like, literally signing the lease
for our second location right now.
And the other thing that was--
- Makes me happy.
(giggles)
- We listen, we listen.
- You know, that's--
- And we're doubling down.
- The biggest vulnerability
to my entire life,
is the part that happens after I say it.
(both agreeing)
You know, it makes me really
happy you're doing that.
- We thought, what can we bring you?
We actually just wanted
to prove our results.
- That's, that's the, I,
and you've got me so pegged.
I want nothing but somebody--
- We've got some cookies.
- Well, thank you.
(laughing)
Do you know what it feels like to know
your business life is better and probly
your life is better because
you listened to the right,
it's the best feeling!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it just made so much sense.
- Absolutely.
I do have a quick question
about (mumbles) influencers,
'cause we're doing a lot more of that.
- We are, yeah.
- And we're attracting
some pretty big people
with huge followings, how
thoughtful should you be
about using influencers, meaning that
if someone could potentially
be a little controversial,
is that potentially
negative for the brand?
- Yeah, sure it could
be, what I was saying
to the crew, and the crew all nodded,
and I reinforced a big thesis of mine,
the market won't be mad at you
for things you can't control,
but if you're looking the other way
because you care about your business,
but you don't care about that racial slur,
or that scam they ran
because you want the thing,
they will not forgive you for that.
So it depends on what you
decide is controversial.
Now, if you're controversial because his,
his training tactic is not, like,
and you believe in it, that's different,
do you see where I'm going?
- Mm-hmm.
- So is it business
controversial, or is it like,
I'm controversial in marketing.
In the marketing world,
a lot of people think
I'm completely full of
shit because they're wrong.
You know, like, I really
mean that, so like,
is his technique of training a dog
or feeding a dog a thing, is that
what's controversial,
but you agree with it?
Or is it like, he punched
a woman, and you're like,
fuck that, got it?
- Yeah.
- So to me, you've gotta context it.
(relaxed music)
(speaking drowned out by music)
Makes me happy, makes me happy.
(relaxed music)
- Nice to meet you.
- Gary.
- Gary, Mike, nice to meet ya.
- Mike, how are you?
- Monica.
- Monica, so nice to meet you.
- What's goin' on, Trevor.
- Trevor, so nice to meet you.
Just give me a few seconds?
- Sure.
- Thank you guys.
Today was a good day to just get some
meetings in just to get back on the field.
- What were you doin' in L.A. then?
- We have a big office there.
- Sure.
- So just normal VaynerMedia stuff,
we had a 4Ds in L.A., what can I answer?
What can I answer, let's bounce around,
we got plenty of time.
- I got one question.
- Go ahead.
- The only question I have.
- What is your thoughts on the comeback
of sounds too good to
be true, 'cause that's
the only hurdle I have,
'cause the math is right,
the teaching's right, education's
right, but they're scared.
- You're gonna appreciate my answer,
I have a very good answer for you,
I would spend zero
seconds convincing people.
The reply is, I respect and understand,
and have empathy for why you think that,
looking forward to conversating
with you in 22 years.
Just don't spend any minutes, go focus
on everybody who is already considering.
- Thank you.
- It will really work for you.
It's been my life, I've been able to win
selling the current because
I go into a meeting with,
and in five minutes, be like,
fuck, this is not gonna work,
and turning an hour meeting
into a 30-minute meeting
because I cordially want
to leave the meeting
because I already know I'm
in a place where it's no.
And I have no emotion
to getting them to yes.
Because history will
prove that I was right.
And so die on your sword, ya know.
- [Guest] You're a Patriots fan?
- But why, that's just,
that's super bandwagon, right?
- [Guest] No. - You better
have gone to Michigan.
- No, Arizona State.
- I heard.
(all laughing)
- [Guest] I believe in discipline
and exactness in everything you do.
- Brother, there's a ton of discipline
and exactness on the Arizona Cardinals.
- [Guest] He's the least
athletic human being
of the whole world, and still wins.
It takes a special skill set--
- Have to be very transparent about this,
I think it's been crazy that he's willing
to back Guerrero when Guerrero is, like,
clearly not a good human being.
I'm so excited for the
BALCO Barry Bonds moment
for Tom Brady, I think Tom, (stammering)
this is, even on film, I genuinely think
Tom's a good dude, I think he's made
a humongous vulnerability to his legacy
in associating so deeply with
a guy who is clearly not good.
- [Guest] If ya have
cancer, drink this water.
- Crazy, I'm fascin, I'll be watch,
in a world where, I said it earlier,
where I see a lotta
kinships with me and him,
I'm like, why in the
world, back to like...
I'm dying to know how
this story plays out,
because nothing makes
sense with his association
with that guy, he is in
business with a guy who is...
Back to internet
marketing and all the shit
I care about, like, don't be that guy,
that's what that guy is,
the guy is selling things
on the internet, only seven years ago,
telling people that if you
drink this, it cures cancer.
(people agreeing)
Who are you?
- [Guest] I get that part.
- I know you do, that's
why I'm leaning into it,
'cause I can tell you do, to me,
in a world where he's
done everything right,
I can't wrap my head around why.
- [Guest] It is gonna be
interesting how it plays out.
- I agree, I think that, look,
I think Brady is suspendable
because he's associating
with him, such a bad guy,
and so my intuition is,
he doesn't get suspended,
but in two years, he coulda,
I think he's putting himself
in a place that he doesn't need to be in.
That's my life at this
point, don't do anything
that makes you vulnerable to the fact
you've done everything right for 25 years.
Why would I do that at this point?
I might as well have done everything wrong
for the last 25 years
to do one singular deal.
It's back to mentors.
- Yeah.
(mumbles)
- Makes sense, right,
and I can't wrap my head
around why, in a world where
I think he's been brilliant,
and is probly a good dude,
based on everything I know,
which I hate that part about it,
hating Jordan's been great,
anybody that actually knows
who he is, he's an outrageously bad dude.
(attendees chuckling quietly)
Like in real life,
whereas Brady is just not.
And this Guerrera thing is really,
I've been, like, pumped about it,
I'll be like, why is he doing this,
this is amazing, I think,
I do think all of you
in six years when there's a
big exposé are gonna be like,
oh shit, 'cause I just think
he can't win that game,
bad is bad, and Guerrero's bad.
I'm tryin' to encourage
people that are happy,
and are good, to share a
little bit more of that.
We're so quick to say, fuck
you Delta and Starbucks,
but we never say, nobody's tweeting how...
DRock will tweet about
the person complaining,
'cause we're so on the same page,
about ice at Starbucks a couple hours ago,
but it's not our natural reaction to say,
oh, great job by the man in front of me
who opened the door for the,
it's just not what we do.
And I'm thinking a lot about that.
Makes sense, right?
(all agreeing)
We don't talk about
good, we talk about bad.
And people that are really
unhappy talk a lot about it.
My first speech ever,
in 2007, I get an email,
come to our internet
conference, so I think
it's internet marketing.
(snickers)
What it was, was internet marketing.
- Ripoff!
- Bless you.
- So I get there, I'll never forget it,
I'm like, what the fuck am I, where am I?
I'm like, is this the
fuckin' red light distr,
you know, I was like, I was freaked.
'Cause I didn't even know it existed.
And I looked around the
room, and what I saw was
people that buy lottery tickets, right.
And so I went up to the
guy, and I was like,
and I had the check, I'll never forget,
and I was like, I don't wanna speak.
And he was like, super,
it was interesting,
I caught the guy at the right time too.
He goes, what do you mean, we talk,
at the A/V station before
I was s'posed to go on.
And I'm like, I'm not gonna
do what that guy just did.
I'm like, do you understand
if I take the stage right now,
I'm gonna spend an hour
shitting on everybody
who just spoke and
breaking this whole thing?
And I don't wanna be disrespectful to you,
I appreciate you flyin' me out here,
you paid me a lot of money, I
wanna give you back the money
'cause I'm not gonna
speak, I need to leave.
And the guy goes, do it. (clicks tongue)
I was like, dude, I'm
serious, he's like, do it.
And I went up there and fuckin' destroyed
the four speakers before, I basically said
they were full of shit.
(all laugh softly)
Why would you buy a $1,000 DVD?
There's this new thing
called the internet.
It's 2007, I'm like, this
Twitter thing's gonna be big,
YouTube's real, people (mumbles)
back to the thing you saw,
that was '11, this was at '07.
Same shit, people are
like, it'd be literally
like me tomorrow going
onstage and being like,
all right, listen, Mars, right?
Here's how you wanna think about Mars,
and everyone's gonna be like,
what the fuck is he doing?
(man chuckles)
That's literally what it was.
Being a con artist, or full of shit,
is really good in the short-term.
The reason I leave money on the
table is 'cause I want a statue.
- Legacy over currency.
- 100%.